what's up everyone welcome back to my
channel Richard on data welcome to my
data science statistics tutorial series
where I give you all the statistics
knowledge that you need to conquer the
data science world I'm going to be
talking about summary metrics of data
here specifically the measures of center
the mean the median and the mode make
sure you watch this video all the way
until the end because I'm gonna go over
how these things are calculated how they
can be used to mislead the non
statistically minded person and also how
they manifest in distributions of data
naturally before I get into these things
I ask that you guys smash the like
button hit the subscribe button and also
hit the notification bell so you never
miss an update from Richard on data
alright so suppose I'm a really nosy
person and I know the income of seven of
my friends let's say those incomes are
forty eight thousand forty eight
thousand fifty three thousand sixty-five
thousand ninety thousand a hundred
thousand and two million so if you look
at the median of those numbers it's
sixty-five thousand the mean of those
numbers is three hundred forty-three
thousand four hundred and twenty-nine
dollars and the mode of those numbers is
48 thousand so notice right off the bat
that all three of those metrics tell a
completely different story so as far as
the mode is concerned that's super
simple forty-eight thousand is our mode
here because it's the only number in
this tiny little data set which appears
more than once it appears twice
everything else appears once because
it's the most frequently occurring
number that's the mode easy that's all
there is to it the median which is also
known as the fiftieth percentile is the
number in the middle if you're listing
your data values from smallest to
largest so you can think of it basically
as the number in which approximately 50%
of your data values are lower than 50%
of your values approximately are higher
than now in this instance we actually
have an odd number of values so it's
literally just the middle number
super-simple if you did have an eve
number of data values you'll take the
middle two numbers add them up and just
divide by two now the mean is what
people are generally referring to when
they talk about an average now the mean
is pretty simply calculated as just the
sum of all the data points divided by
the total individual number of data
points it's also known as the expected
value and it's commonly denoted either
by the Greek letter mu or by the symbol
e of X which basically means the
expected value of some random variable X
just as a disclaimer please keep in mind
that I'm only using seven numbers here
in a pretty silly example about my
friends income because it's easy to do
the math in your head and visualize
these things as well as to quickly see
the massive discrepancies between the
mean the median and the mode in this
particular case now if I were taking a
sample because I wanted to make some
inference about a population maybe in
this case I'm super nosy and I want to
understand what the average income of
the population of all of my friends is I
would actually need two things number
one I would need a random sample that's
representative of my entire population
and I would also need a larger sample
size than seven but that's a whole
separate topic for a separate video so
notice in our example here the mean is
substantially higher than the median is
and that's just an artifact of the way a
mean is calculated so the mean is gonna
end up being highly susceptible to
outliers and it gets pulled in one
direction or another as a result of that
so really pay attention if you're
analyzing your data and you see a large
discrepancy between your mean and your
median that's going to mean that you
have outliers and outliers generally are
gonna inspire some questions you might
have outliers in your data which are
even accurate or you figure out from
those outliers there's actually
something else going on and you may not
even have data which accurately reflects
what you think it does so these are just
questions that you have to think about
and really talk to yourself and to your
stakeholders about you'll often want to
give some serious thought to what's
causing these outliers
based on your own understanding of the
data and the domain knowledge associated
with it so just be really nuanced when
you're talking with stakeholders about
averages because these seems simple at
first but you can unveil some things you
didn't even know when you start really
digging into them and if the stakeholder
only asks you for one average just give
some really serious thought about which
number you're mean or your median really
accurately reflects the nature of your
data a little better there's no exact
science behind this it's something that
you'll have to figure out in every
individual case alright lastly let's
look at how these things actually
manifest in distributions of data first
of all the easiest way to visualize the
shape of a distribution is by making a
histogram in these cases here you can
see histograms which are smooth out a
little bit more so they kind of start to
take on more of a pacman ghostie shape
the normal distribution has a lot of
really nice properties to it one of them
is the fact that the mean is going to be
equal to the median is gonna be equal to
the mode it gets a little bit more
complicated though when we start talking
about data that's skewed to the left or
data that's skewed to the right
so take left skewed data for instance
now this can be a little tricky at first
but in a left skewed data set you're
going to have a lot of outliers which
are on the left side compared to most of
your data points being on the right side
so it's a little counterintuitive at
first but you end up with a shape like
this what ends up happening in these
situations most of the time is that the
outliers on the left side are gonna pull
the mean in that direction the mode is
where the most data points end up
showing up and the median is going to be
somewhere in the middle so the mean is
less than the median is less than the
mode right skewed data is very similar
to left skewed data and it's actually
probably significantly more common
distributions which are used to model a
lot of real-life phenomena called the
exponential and the gamma distributions
will generally take on a right skewed
form this is where a lot of your
is on the left side but you have
outliers on the right side pulling the
distribution in that direction so in
this instance your mode is on the left
where most of your data is slightly
greater than that is your median and
then the outliers on the right side
aren't gonna pull the mean in that
direction so you have the opposite
situation as the left skewed case you
have the mode less than the median less
than the mean most of the time that
covers it from mean median and mode now
you know how these things are calculated
the stipulations around them and how
they can be used to deceive people and
then also how they manifest in
distributions of data like these so
thanks for watching this video until
next time Richard on data